The day is finally here, today is the end
of the Donald Trump era, it is the start of
the presidency of Joe Biden, who will be or
has already been sworn in.
By the time you listen to today's show, by
the time you watch this clip, it has felt
like so long.
And at the same time, it feels like just yesterday
that I was watching those numbers come in
from Florida at seven twenty five p.m. Eastern
Time in November of 2016 and thinking this
isn't looking quite so good for Hillary Clinton,
but we've talked about all that.
And today is the day where Trump out, Biden
in, and finally the beginning of getting beyond
the global historic nightmare that has been
the Trump administration.
But Donald Trump did not leave quietly.
Yes, he was quiet on Twitter because he was
suspended.
Yes.
We didn't see any live press conference or
speech from Donald Trump in the lead up to
his final days.
But Trump was never going to leave totally
quietly.
And he delivered yesterday a deranged and
meandering screed of a speech.
We will look only at a few clips today.
We are also glad to be getting beyond this.
But it's important to know what were the last
utterances to slip from Trump's mouth.
The theme yesterday in this prerecorded speech,
the theme was Trump taking credit for really
anything that he could even just general delusions
of grandeur like this one with the support
and prayers of the American people.
We achieve more than anyone thought possible.
Nobody thought we could even come close.
Of course, whatever achievements you think
did take place during this Trump administration
historically will be outweighed dramatically
by the massive, overwhelming failures of the
administration on everything in particular
uncovered on global relations, on climate.
And I could go on and as I've said before,
had Trump properly handled the virus response,
it would be Trump being sworn in for four
more years today, not Joe Biden.
We saw it happen in other countries and that
was Trump's undoing.
He couldn't control that.
He had to deal with the virus.
Nobody could.
But proper handling of the virus did lead
to reelections for leaders that handled it
correctly, Trump wildly and incorrectly claiming
that now the world respects us and warns that
we should avoid losing the respect he believes
or claims to have secured for the United States.
Completely delusional.
And we know we know that for a fact.
Take a look.
The world respects us again.
Please don't lose that respect.
So this has been widely studied.
We don't have to speculate.
We don't have to guess.
We don't need conjecture, respect for the
United States around the world.
Absolutely.
In the toilet.
You know those toilets.
Trump says he would have to flush ten or fifteen
times if Joe Biden's environmental regulations
get in.
Well, that's where the global reputation is
for the United States in the toilet.
And the challenge will actually be the opposite
of what Donald Trump says it will be.
Can Joe Biden restore respect for the United
States?
With Trump gone, what countries are willing
to say?
OK, let's let's let's reestablish mutual trust
and respect after Trump is gone.
I think many countries will be willing to
do that because it matters that we reestablish
those alliances.
It matters for them as much as it matters
for us.
But no Trump with opposite opposite day speech,
the respect was lost under Trump.
Trump also, interestingly, saying he deliberately
chose the tough battles rather than taking
the easy path he sort of framed during this
prerecorded speech that was released yesterday.
He said, you know, part of what made his admin,
his presidency tough was he chose to do the
tough things, sort of an illusion in some
sense to John F. Kennedy.
But failing miserably to make any kind of
analogy as president, my top priority, my
constant concern has always been the best
interests of American workers and American
families.
I did not seek the easiest course by far.
It was actually the most.
I took on the tough battles, the hardest fights,
the most difficult choices, because that's
what you elected me to do.
Your needs were my first and last unyielding
focus.
This, I hope, will be our greatest legacy.
This one is interesting because in a way,
it's sort of a positive moment.
He's not attacking anyone necessarily, not
directly anyway.
But it's also very disconnected from reality.
He actually chose easy things and mess.
I'm up, and he also messed up things that
every president has to deal with, and he also
messed up things that every world leader was
presented with and dealt with better than
Trump coronavirus, of course, being at the
top of that list.
Trump did say, and I think this is the closest
I've ever heard Trump be to conciliatory in
any way.
Trump said he is praying for the success of
the next administration.
But there's a little weird tweak, he adds,
in there that I want to talk about.
This week, we inaugurate a new administration
and pray for its success in keeping America
safe and prosperous.
We extend our best wishes and we also want
them to have luck.
A very important word.
Trump has to add something snarky or weird,
and it's Trump mentioning luck.
And this is a reference to Trump seeing himself
as having had bad luck that he had to deal
with the coronavirus pandemic.
But more importantly, Trump didn't even mention
Joe Biden.
In this 20 minute speech, Trump mentions the
next administration, as he did in these vague
terms, about eight to 10 days ago.
But he never says Joe Biden and he didn't
say it today in another final screed that
we will get to.
And it is another one of these signals about
the petulant child that is Donald Trump.
Now, it is true that without Trump's mishandling
of the pandemic, he would have been reelected.
I talked about that moments ago.
But Trump handling the pandemic well is not
a question of luck.
It's just a question of who was determined
to do it and who was capable of doing it.
As we saw many world leaders do, the bad luck
was actually for us.
The bad luck was for the world that we were
so unlucky that it was Trump in power when
the global hundred year pandemic hit just
about anyone else, including just, you know,
a high school science teacher.
And like anybody who would have just said,
oh, this is a situation where we need experts,
let's defer to them from day one would have
worked out better than having Trump in power.
That's bad luck for us.
It wasn't Trump's bad luck.
Trump wrapping up the end of this prerecorded
speech by taking a page out of Kimberly Guilfoyle
playbook.
And remember, from the Republican National
Convention, the best is yet to come.
You remember that?
Here's Trump using that phrase.
I go from this majestic place with a loyal
and joyful heart and optimistic spirit and
a supreme confidence that for our country
and for our children, the best is yet to come.
Thank you and farewell.
God bless you.
God bless the United States of America.
So another lame speech to cap off a lame failed
presidency that we are thrilled to see finally
over and noticed that in this entire speech,
Trump didn't mention Joe Biden.
As I said earlier, he completely glossed over
400000 coronavirus deaths, although he mentioned
that this morning he glosses over the pro
Trump riots that he inspired at the Capitol
two weeks ago.
And the militarized state of the city is,
Trump believes, thanks to him.
And it is yet another pathetic joke.
Now one little extra goodbye.
On his way out, Trump revoked the executive
order that banned administration officials
from becoming lobbyists within five years
of leaving government drain the swamp.
Right, my friends.
And that's something that really should be
codified into law rather than left up to administrations.
We will be covering the inauguration.
But first, Trump's final weird sort of rally
like goodbye happened this morning.
Let's talk
about
that next.